it was right before Christmas and I was
drunk in Atlanta
and uh
uh I wanted to go get some food right my
whole crew with us we're in Buckhead my
whole crew that was with me they didn't
want to go get any food so then I met
this random fella uh spiky air kind of
reddish uh he was like man like what's
good gravy let's let's go get some pizza
and I was like hell yeah so we walked
like two blocks and then there's DeKalb
Tire right tire store right there on the
Block
middle Buckhead oh yeah he was like yo
man this is my dad's my dad's shot it's
my dad's place you wanna go inside I was
like of course yeah let's get it so we
got we go around back and he tastes like
a sort of like a shovel and like props
open the garage door in the back and I
guess I just figured it was normal I was
like this is
since I get into your dad's business man
it's all good yeah let me get in there
we're [ __ ] around like we're in this
tire store like some of the lights are
on we're just jumping around we're like
Rolling Tires back just some drunk dumb
[ __ ] Rolling Tires back and forth
climbing on Pilots like having a good
time
[ __ ] erotic dog dude it was it was
just like some home some bonding shoe at
the home and man I don't even remember I
don't remember I know what you're saying
yeah I remember his [ __ ] name anyways
yeah I am just like look down on my
phone because somebody called me and I
like look back up and I just like look
around I'm like body is gone he's
completely gone and I couldn't remember
what his name was so I'm in this tire
store I was like all the [ __ ] laying
around I'm like [ __ ] man like what do I
do so I just I just walk out the back
door and there's three cops there like
guns out like flashlight on me like get
in the [ __ ] ground could he set you
up you think oh no it didn't set me up I
think what do you I think
his dad didn't know it it was it was
some random kid who somehow knew that
like he could get in the back of his
tire shop he brought me in there and we
were like just [ __ ] around and then
he must have noticed that there was like
a cop car or something he ran and then I
just walked out like innocently and
there's three cops waiting and I got
[ __ ] arrested for breaking and
entering into a tire store oh dang bro
you know what I ended up doing bro my
Midwestern self man after all that I
went to jail for the night it was dude I
I was in a cell with all these dudes and
they were just oh man it was I had to
Freestyle to like get to gain some you
know toilet access I'm sure yeah I was
on a huge sale I had to gain some credit
by freestyling wow was that scary when
you first went in a little bit but I was
like I mean I was like just stand out I
was just kind of geeking out I was like
man I can't believe this is what led me
here uh but it was Fulton County so it
was like like you know mid mid-atlanta
uh only white dude there for sure did
anybody recognize you in the jail cell
there's one kid yeah yeah but I was like
I was just like nah let's not now I had
no explanation I was like Yeah man so so
my homie his dad owns the place like
it's all good like what's his name I was
like
ah I hate you with that hard question I
was like [ __ ] I don't know man I was
drunk wow yeah that tire shop man we've
all been in some kind of instance like
that we're just yeah wrong place man I
think it was Christmas Christmas Eve
that my friend built me out the next
morning it's Christmas Eve god it feels
good getting out of jail doesn't it
something nice about it so good dude
when when they come in yourself because
because they don't pay attention in jail
if you're if you're in there if you have
any questions anything you even want to
like you know even want food you little
turned on the AC on you get your ass all
cold and [ __ ] anything you want they'll
just not even look at you if you ask for
it but like when that dude comes in and
finally says like yo Matthew Harry
it's your time to go
I think I showed a tear just about every
time we had last dude that's almost
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one